[Music]  hey what's up guys it's marquez from the  mkbhd channel happy friday and welcome  to forum friday where every week we ask  a simple question that requires a simple  answer for this week the very simple  question is this what is your default  web browser is google chrome is it  firefox is it opera is it internet ex  is it chromium is it some alpha build of  some web browser are you going crazy  with web browsers do you use a lot of  them just all you have to do is name it  below you don't have to argue about what  is better just name whatever hours are  you using the most popular answer from  this week will be revealed in next  week's form friday episode thanks in  advance for your comment and be sure to  like this video which supports this  series see you next week guys mkbhd  signing out peace  [Music]  you